do you know the position that has
emerged as the key to success in the
dynamic and always changing corporate
world the business analyst as
organizations strive to adapt innovate
and Thrive the need for skilled
professionals who can navigate
complexities solve problems and drive
strategic decision making has never been
great whether you are a seasoned
professional looking to enhance your
skill set or an aspiring business
analyst ready to embark on an exciting
career understanding this role's
essential skills is the key to unlock
your full potential so are you ready to
unlock the secret of rapidly growing
field and become a business analyst in
today's Dynamic business world then
demand for skilled professionals who can
drive change and maximize value is
skyrocketing the key for your success
lies in mastering a rebirth set of
skills that will open up new
opportunities and Propel you towards a
thriving career are you interested in
becoming a business analyst but unsure
where to start simply learns both
graduate program in business analysts
can help you gain the skills and
experience you need to succeed in the
dynamic field this program provides a
comprehensive understanding of business
analysis including data analysis
business process modeling and project
management the program is delivered
through live instructor-led classes and
Hands-On projects you can work on real
world business problems and gain
practical experience this program is
also designed to help you prepare for
industry certifications including the
certified business analyst professional
cbap so if you are ready to take your
career to the next level and become a
business analyst enroll now in simply
learns postgraduate program in business
analysis today with simply learn you can
learn anytime anywhere and at your own
pace the link will be in the description
box below do check it out so without
further Ado let's start with the videos
agenda and see the top 10 essential
skills to become a business analyst
let's see the agenda for this video
first we will see who is a business
analyst after that we will see the
skills required to become a business
analyst and then last we will see the
salary and job of a business analyst so
who is a business analyst business
analysts have a key role in the
organization performing Financial
operations they are in responsible for
creating economic growth in the
organization the action and decision
taken by the business analysts will
impact the growth of the organization
business analysts understand the complex
business problems and providing
innovative solutions that benefit all
stakeholders from formulating strategies
to decision and designing Enterprises
architectures business analysts are
involved in every aspect of the business
life cycle they document processes
Elevate business models and ensure that
project aligned with the organization's
objectives now that you know what
business analyst is let me give you a
perspective of one of our Learners who
accelerated their career as a business
analyst so that you can better
understand the pathway to our career
I have many small gaps and short
Employments in my career
I even have a huge two-year career Gap
due to some health issues however I
think the dark times are now behind me
hi I'm Cortana rujek I live in Raleigh
North Carolina and working as a business
analyst at levator
it's my second job since I completed the
postgraduate program in physics
analytics I simply learned with Purdue
University in December 2021.
my experience with simplen was great the
life classes were my favorite because
they were very interactive and I could
connect with instructors
Claus had a comprehensive curriculum I
could also record the promises for
future reference the final project of
practical and advantages with flexible
deadlines for competition
my understanding of all the crown
circles and Haze as a result of this I'm
6 first Grandmaster ecba product owner
and agile coach
in the near future I would like to see
myself grow as a business analyst
be totally honest with you Reviving my
professional career was not an easy task
I'd like to go on and you need to trust
yourself and keep pushing it doesn't
matter how challenging the path may be
keep upscaling and one day you will
achieve successful life
foreign
to the top 10 essential skills that will
pave your way to becoming a successful
business analyst till in this role you
need a blend of Technical and
non-technical proficiencies so let's
explore the skills that will set you
apart from the rest the first one in our
list is understanding the business
objective first and foremost a business
analyst must grab the organization's
objective and challenges this means
having a deep understanding of the
business landscape and the ability to
identify and implement the most
effective Solutions domain knowledge
within the organization fault is a
valuable aspect that enhances your
deliverables after all the ultimate goal
is to drive sales boost production and
improve Revenue systems the next one is
communication and interpersonal skills
but wait there's more communication and
interpersonal skills are vital for
Effective collaboration with
stockholders and clients you must be a
master of articular communication
ensuring that your ideas facts and
opinions are clearly conveyed whether
you are launching a project collecting
requirements or validating the final
solution your verbal and brightens
communication skills will be cattle for
Success the next we have analytical and
critical thinking
analytical and critical thinking skills
for the Bedrock of a business analyst
toolkit as Thomas Edison once said only
a small percentage of people truly think
as a business analyst you must
diligently analyze and translate client
requirements leveraging critical
thinking to elevate multiple options and
prioritize business needs your ability
to think analytically empowers you to
achieve goals even when resources are
limited and conditions are less than
ideal next we have decision making
skills as a business analyst your
decision holds tremendous weight that's
why decision making skills are crucial
you must consider all expats into
prepared problems explore alternate
approaches test solution and ensure that
technical design aligned with the
business requirement your ability to
make informed decision will settle the
company towards success next we have
negotiation and cost benefit analysis
are skills that every business analyst
must processes as you navigate various
project phases you navigate your
negotiation skills will determine
project Vision prioritize requirements
and make critical technical decisions
additionally conducting throughout cost
benefit analysis will enables you to
assess the variabilities of new projects
and guide organization towards fruitful
endurance next we have is programming
languages now let's dive into the
technical skills that will augment your
business analysis Powers programming
languages such as RN python are
indecipiable for efficient data analysis
with their Rich libraries and packages
for data wrangling manipulation
visualization and analytics you will be
equipped to tackle complex problems and
make accurate business predictions
additionally a solid grasp of statical
software like SAS and Spas is highly
recommended the next we have creation of
reports and dashboards creating reports
and dashboard is another critical skills
for business analysts Proficiency in
tools like Tableau and power bi is
essential for generating insightful
reports that drive informative decision
making your ability to visualize data
and present it in a compelling manner
will be valuabled to stockholders next
we have database and SQL knowledge of
databases and SQL is a must have for any
business analyst working with structured
data relational databases like Microsoft
SQL Server MySQL Oracle database and
nosql databases are your playing feed
hands-on experience with SQL allows you
to access retirees manipulate and
analyze data efficiently empowering you
to extract valuable insights the next we
have Microsoft Excel let's not forget
the Timeless power of Microsoft Excel
this fundamental skill is the backbone
of analytics and reporting for business
analysts Excel enables you to perform
calculation data analysis budget
analysis and create Dynamic reports from
revenue growth model to expense tracking
Excel will be your trusty companion
throughout your career next we have
documentation and presentation last but
not the least documentation and
presentation skills are pronoun as a
business analyst you must document your
project findings and present them
confidently to stockholders and clients
organized and conscious documentation
helps bridge the gap between the
technical Concepts and non-technical
employees by recording projects lessons
you equip yourself with valuable
knowledge for future decision making and
problem solving now that you have
discovered the essential skills of
business analyst it's time to embark on
your journey to success simply learn is
your trusted partner in this endurance
offering comprehensive training program
that will transform you into a highly
skilled business analyst so are you
ready to seize the opportunity and
unlock the world of possibilities let's
simply learn be your guide as you
navigate the exciting part to becoming a
successful business analyst now once you
raise this course and acquired skills
then you can apply for these job
profiles the first one is entry level
business analyst in India the salary
range for ND level business analyst is
typically between 3 lakh to 6 lakh per
year and in U.S the salary range for a
entry-level business analyst is
approximately between 50 000 US dollar
to 70 000 US dollar per annum now let's
see the education and Foundation that
you will be needing first you'll need to
get a bachelor degree in Business
Administration computer science or a
related field it's like building a
strong Foundation of your career to
boost your credentials you can also
consider getting certifications like
from Simply after that sharpen your
skills acquire domain knowledge and
develop your analytical skills by
learning tools like Excel SQL and data
visualization software these are like
secret weapons that will help you
analyze data and find important insights
you should also learn problem solving
methods and how the model processes
works
it's like becoming a problem solving
superhero the next is hands-on
experience to really level up look for
internships entry-level positions or
projects within your organization this
will give you a practical experience and
allow you to contribute to requirement
Gathering documentation and testing it's
like going on a real-time Mission and
making a tangible impact by following
these steps you will be well on your way
to becoming a skilled business analyst
you will be the hero who helps
businesses make smart decision and drive
success now let's talk about senior
business analyst salary
for senior business analyst in India the
salary range can be between 6 lakh to 12
lakh per year in us the salary range for
a senior business analyst is typically
between 70 000 US dollar to 100 000 US
dollar per annum for education and
Foundation consider pursuing a master
degree in Business Administration or a
related field to deepen your knowledge
and expertise explore Advance
certifications like certified business
analyst profession scbap or project
management professional
cpmp acquired domain knowledge continue
expanding your understanding of the
industry and its strength challenges and
embarking Technologies developing a deep
understanding of a specific business
domain within the industry the next I
want to tell you about is analytical
skill development enhance your data
analysis compatibilities by exploring
Advanced Technologies predicting
modeling and data visualization
familiarize yourself with the business
intelligence tools and Advanced
Analytical platforms and in last we have
lead business analyst the salary range
for a lead business analyst in India can
vary from 12 lakh to 25 lakh per year
and in U.S the salary range for a lead
business analyst is typically between
100 000 US dollar per annum to 150 000
US dollar per annum next is education
and Foundation take Advanced
certification and specialized training
in leadership and business strategy
consider getting a MBA or another
Advanced degree to expand your knowledge
in business
next we have business analysis
techniques Master the art of facilating
and negotiating in complex stack holders
engagements promote best practices in
managing requirements analyzing their
impact and validating Solutions then
last is hands-on experience take the
lead on strategic implementation and
large-scale project play a significant
role in shaping your organization's
business analysis process and
methodologies and last I would say
everyone processes at their own base
based on their skills opportunities and
Industry demands keep seeking
professional development
on challenging tasks and relationship
within the industry to accelerate your
growth as a business analyst
so with this we have read the end of
this video make sure to like and share
this video And subscribe to Simply
learns YouTube channel thank you
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign